[Música]
momento de economía aquí en directo a
América edición nocturna de France 24 y
ya está Juan Pablo lucumí en el estudio
listo para comenzar Así es aquí estamos
de nuevo y con qué empezamos esta
Crónica Juan Pablo qué nos trae Pues
nosotros empezamos con la inversión
extranjera que hubo en América Latina y
el Caribe porque entre 2021 y 2022 la
inversión extranjera directa en esta
región se incrementó en un 55,2% según
informes de la cepal estamos hablando de
las que la cifra alcanzó los
224.579 millones de dólares el máximo
valor que lleva registrado Pues esta
comisión de la ONU el principal
favorecido de esta inversión fue Brasil
la principal economía de la región con
un 41% del total de las entradas seguido
de México con el 17% chile con el 9%
Colombia con el 8 y Argentina con el 7%
podemos ver que aquí están básicamente
las principales economías de la región
cerca de la mitad de estos recursos
fueron destinados a empresas que ya
operaban en los países y la ONU dijo que
pues uno de los grandes retos es que
esta inversión No se concentre en una
sola ciudad como suele pasar en las
capitales sino que pueda ser distribuida
por el resto del país y Juan Pablo
continuamos con más economía de la
región hay una negociación en marcha
entre Argentina y Bolivia de qué estamos
hablando una negociación que se espera
que sea consumada en los próximos días
porque el embajador de Argentina en
Bolivia Ariel basteiro dijo que
negociaría una adenda para fijar las
nuevas condiciones de compra de gas
natural boliviano a partir de 2024 ante
una eventual disminución del
requerimiento de ese recurso este
anuncio ocurre Solo un día después de
que Argentina haya inaugurado el primer
tramo del nuevo gasoducto presidente
Néstor kirchner que tiene el objetivo de
otorgar a ese país lo que han llamado
como soberanía energética y convertirlo
así en un proveedor Internacional del
energético pero muchos se preguntarán
Entonces cómo para esto Pues el
embajador basteiro señaló que su país va
a poder ahorrar la mitad de lo que se
está gastando y según él habrá un nuevo
tramo del gasoducto que podría estar
finalizado para fin de 2024 bueno
pasemos a Colombia porque una comisión
independiente alertó del manejo que da
el gobierno al gasto social así es y uno
les empieza ya a llamar como unas
cuentas alegres que empieza a hacer el
gobierno pues al manejo actual y también
a los proyectos que el presidente de ese
país planea que se implementen a futuro
el comité autónomo de la regla fiscal
aseguró este lunes que el presupuesto de
Colombia de 2024 deja muy poco espacio
para atender sorpresas de gasto y deja
poca maniobra para cumplir la regla
fiscal si se presenta alguna
eventualidad el 15 de junio del
Ministerio de Hacienda de ese país
presentó una actualización del marco
fiscal a mediano plazo y en él se
presenta un mayor déficit fiscal para
2023 y 2024 esto debido al panorama de
desaceleración en la economía Colombia
con el que pues esperan también menores
ingresos para el país Además del precio
del dólar y el precio del petróleo que
lo hemos estado hablando aquí que pues
ha disminuido también bastante en
resumen esta entidad dice que el
gobierno colombiano planea aumentar el
gasto sin saber cómo serán sus ingresos
permanentes todo esto sin mencionar que
el gobierno de Petro todavía está
impulsando reformas de la sanidad y de
pensiones en el congreso y tiene
previsto también volver a presentar una
reforma laboral que no avanzó
anteriormente Juan Pablo indicadores
vamos entonces con Wall Street porque
cerró en verde este lunes y el dow Jones
de las empresas industriales subió un
0,62% Mientras que el nasdaq que cotizan
las tecnologías más importantes ganó un
ligero 0,18% en lo que supone el
principal inicio de la semana y cuando
se vienen datos económicos este pues
durante la semana América Latina en
cambio inició la semana con pérdidas los
principales indicadores de México y
Brasil Pues de las dos principales
economías de la región cerraron este en
números rojos Juan Pablo antes de
despedir esta Crónica Cuál es la cifra
del día pues no podría ser otra rosa si
no los 100 millones de usuarios que
alcanzó la plataforma frets el nuevo
rival de Twitter en apenas cinco días de
lanzamiento según sitios especializados
que también dan cuenta que esto equivale
a la mitad de los usuarios que tiene la
red de elon musk y acá podemos ver más o
menos Cómo ha sido el panorama lo
alcanzó en 5 días superando así la que
tenía el primer lugar que era charge
pity pero alcanzó en dos meses tiktokers
nueve meses y en instagram que es una
aplicación que conocemos muchos que
mucho la usamos la alcanzó en 2,5 años
se demoró bastante pero ya podemos ver
cómo Pues están las descargas de esta
aplicación pues la gran incógnita es la
consolidación no finalmente de esta
nueva red social la Seguiremos Cuánto
puede durar exactamente Juan Pablo
Muchísimas gracias por esta Crónica
mañana con mucho más Rosa